[Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  thank god david hello we need your help  michael is everyone okay oh  well i'm afraid not  [Music]  happy  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  happy  [Music]  happy  [Music]  uh  [Music]  [Music]  ah  [Music]  my  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  so  [Music]  just like what is this  [Music]  the  love is that confident  [Music]  about the matrix  [Music]  [Music]  i got  [Music]  uh  [Music]  i got a baby  [Music]  it's like  [Music]  bottom  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  yes  [Music]  this wouldn't happen  [Music]  i  [Music]  [Music]  blow it  [Music]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  okay  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Music]  huh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  teamwork  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  um  [Music]  laughter  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  i hate to be going backwards all this  time  [Music]  you